[Music]
i'm vim kraussweg
i collect messages in bottles from the
beach
in 34 years
i collected over 1200 messages in
bottles
i have all the time in the world and
instead of talking with other old people
i love to walk on the beach and see the
surprises
[Music]
[Music]
in 1983 i found three of them so i wrote
them that i was surprised to find these
messages and the other surprise was that
i got answers of all three of them
and that's when i decided okay i'm a
collector of messages in bottles
i find my messages and models on the
beach of sanford where i live and on the
dutch islands
messages in bottles is slow mail it
takes you
days
weeks or months
to
find a bottle
and i don't even on the beach open them
i put them in my rug pack and at home i
open them to have a second surprise
this is the german girl the first letter
she wrote me on the 28th
of august in 1983.
it pleased me to receive your letter
[Music]
writing is something you can think about
what you're writing when you're talking
with somebody you're interrupted and
getting an answer before you expect it
when you write something you can write
on your own nobody is interrupting you
and when you get an answer i cannot
interrupt them
even when i have been writing only a few
times with somebody i got to know him
and when i'm going through this
collection and i see the message then i
remember how much fun we had for a while
[Music]
this is david deutschman
this is david deutschman that's better
for the last 12 years david has held
over 1200 babies at scottish rite
hospital hey david when can i raise my
voice after the titles appear
[Music]
at children's healthcare of atlanta
you'll find david volunteering as a baby
buddy a person that spends time holding
babies who are delivered prematurely or
requires special medical attention when
i first came to work for the hospital
they gave me a little baby to hold and
the child life person walked by and said
hey you hold babies i've got a job for
you and i just loved it i became
nicknamed by a few nurses as the baby
whisperer all right buddy i'd be given a
baby who was screaming crying
[Music]
you'd be amazed how quickly they can
calm down
because the babies stay in the hospital
for a long period of time most parents
can't stick around mainly because their
maternity leave runs out or they have
other kids at home that's where david
comes in david has gone on to hold
countless babies in the neonatal
intensive care unit providing not only
companionship but other medical benefits
as well just ask nurse angie we find
that holding also can help mitigate some
pain so when our babies have heel sticks
done and they're being held they react
so much better than when they're not
held
david has done this for so long now when
he takes a baby into his arms you can
see the baby relax because david's so
relaxed so you feel the baby's in good
hands
if you're a retiree i would say to you
get off your button do something
volunteer doing something and there are
a lot of different ways of doing it it
doesn't have to be in a children's
hospital
i know it meant a lot to the moms and
the dads too but what it meant for me
i really feel that
i'm the one who benefited
[Music]
extraordinary birthdays is an
organization that i created to instill
self-worth and homeless children on
their birthday
when i started you know somebody said
you know it's just a birthday you know i
mean my god they need a house they need
this i'm like yeah they need to be
recognized too
[Music]
i'm chanelle leake and i'm the founder
of extraordinary birthdays we go and
partner with shelters to provide
personalized birthday parties for
homeless children i want every child to
feel like their parents ordered this
party up we're just the people that are
helping to make it happen
that says unicorn all day long right
it's like super cute since 2010 we have
celebrated over 800 kids i started with
one shelter and in 2011 you know we got
another shelter and we are now up to
nine shelters and that's in dc maryland
and virginia
extraordinary birthdays is not just me
we have our party planners they are the
heart and soul of eob because they are
planning parties for children they don't
know
that is hard to do goodie bags
now that is over the top and they're
putting all of this together from the
plates to the napkins the tablecloths
they are creating the centerpieces all
of this will be part of that efforts we
do into transforming the shelter
[Music]
one of my greatest joys is their first
response when they come in the room
their expectations are so low that when
they come in they just they can't
believe this party
and we've hit it on the head every
single time so we have this
questionnaire that basically has the
children's name their age who's coming
we usually say to them give us three
things on your wish list three things
that they want
this is also part of her gift i didn't
bring her other gifts but i will have
them tomorrow um because they were super
huge okay
[Music]
and then we always ask them what kind of
cake
and how awesome is it that we are able
to fill that because that's specifically
what that child wants
[Music]
the people that come to the parties are
other children in the shelter when a
child is homeless they're not inviting
their friends from school their friends
from school don't know they live in a
shelter
their friends are in the shelter so we
really are too about building this
community it's more about the birthday
child but it's about
the culture of those other homeless
children too because they're going away
with goodie bags just like everyone else
and these are things that are speaking
to them in quiet ways even though it's
not their birthday we are still having
some type of impact on that child for
that moment
this mother said
something so profound to me she says
when you are homeless
the system reminds you of that every day
she said my daughter did something
normal today she went to a birthday
party
for that moment
that mom was able to be a mom
so the children get to see their parents
as parents
and not in a line getting food or you
know being part of the handout and
that's what i love because what i wanted
to do
is to take the simple concept of a
birthday party and disrupt everyone's
thinking
[Music]
over 2 billion cups of coffee are
consumed every day and it takes a lot of
people to make just one cup
one man went on a quest to figure out
what it's like to thank each and every
one of them
[Music]
aj jacobs is a writer who lives in new
york city hi i'm aj
and he's the first to admit he can be a
bit of a grouch
my default state is grumpiness i am very
good at noticing all the things that go
wrong
so to make a change he started giving
thanks during dinner
i would say
thank you to everyone who helped make my
meal until one night my 10 year old son
was like you know dad those people can't
hear you if you really cared you would
go and thank these people in person and
that's when the light bulb went off he
decided to hone in on something he knew
he took for granted every day
my morning cup of coffee
over the next 12 months aj set out to
thank every single person who had even
the smallest role in his morning cup of
joe
first it was his local barista the
roaster and the coffee shop sorcerer
whenever i thanked one person they would
say well i couldn't do my job without
this person so one person led to another
led to another led to another he
ventured outside the city and eventually
the country i thank the folks who
provide electricity to the coffee shop
the engineers who provide the water the
people who make the steel
the farmer and the importer the truck
driver
the person who paved the road even the
woman who painted the yellow lines in
the rose so that my coffee beans could
safely arrive at my coffee shop i
remember i called the woman who does
pest control for the warehouse and i
said i know this sounds strange but i
want to thank you for keeping the
insects out of my coffee and she said
well that does sound strange but thank
you you know i don't get a lot of
appreciation in my job
all in aj ended up thanking over 1 000
different people and while most were
pleasantly surprised by his gratitude
it's aj who benefited the most
the experience has made me grateful for
the hundreds of things that go right
every day as opposed to the three or
four that go wrong i tell my friends
that they should try these gratitude
trails themselves it could just be small
gestures looking someone in the eye the
cashier at the drugstore it could be
sending a quick note to the designer of
a logo you love i will tell you that it
will make your life better it's changed
the way i live my life
[Music]
you